so we at ET love this is us so much that
we've actually named it one of our ones
to wash of the 2016 season thank you so
much we appreciate it thank you how
could you possibly want me right now in
any state my wife you were ask me you've
gotta talk about the very first scene
that we see you in with that pregnant
belly oh sure it floats in there I loves
but that's normally how people made it
off the trailer somehow has been viewed
collectively like 91 million times and I
think a lot of it has to do with my Lois
took it but I'm but yes I have a
pregnant belly because I'm pregnant with
triplets in the pilot so I had a like
wearing that I had a 35-pound prosthetic
belly which many women have pointed out
to me like that looks like you're
pregnant with one child not three and I
was like it's television triplets yeah
cuz there was like no hip weight added
no but wait you know like so yeah it was
all in the belly which I suspect is not
a you know a real thing fill me in the
pilot you now have been working with so
many little babies what's that been like
for you
well we actually only worked with babies
in the pilot we where we haven't we just
started up a so too but um it definitely
gets the ovaries kicking a little bit
because I'm not a mom so I'm like ah one
day it's good practice right and you had
said that you have some song opportunity
is stored up in your head
anymore elbow I don't know when but but
sooner rather than later it's been like
seven years since I played music and now
that I feel like this part of my life is
percolating and the ball is rolling
again I feel like that'll sort of free
up my the creative space in my brain and
my heart to kind of put it all down we
want it so yes thank you I'll get back
to it